MARK MIRCHANDANI: So you want
to harness the power of machine
learning for your business.
Well, one of the first
problems you'll need to solve
is what data you'll be
using to teach your models.
So you guys have
like a mantra, right?
SPEAKER: Yes no data, no ML.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What
does that mean exactly?
SPEAKER: Well,
your model is only
as good as the
data it trains on.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Luckily,
our professional services
ML team has refined a
set of best practices
for selecting and
preparing top quality data.
And we're itching to
hand the goods over.
SPEAKER: Is this the
part where we tell them
all of our secrets?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That comes
up in a little bit later.
First, we'll reveal
what goes into choosing
a highly effective
data source, and later,
learn how to spot the
most common oversights
our professional services ML
team helps correct for clients.
So ready to become an
independent authority
on good data?
Let's dive in.
Rule number 1, clear labels.
Many companies use
machine learning
because they want to
predict some outcome,
from detecting credit card fraud
to forecasting ice cream sales,
from recommendation systems
to self-driving cars.
Whatever it is you're
trying to predict,
you'll need to feed the
machine some examples
with known outcomes.
We call those labels.
If you were teaching
a machine how
to predict credit card
fraud, for instance,
you would tell the machine
for each new piece of data
whether or not fraud occurred.
This is what we mean
by known outcomes.
It may seem like a small point,
but for businesses looking
to take advantage of ML to
make accurate predictions,
these labeled examples
are what allow algorithms
to learn in the first place.
SPEAKER: I would
say this is probably
the number one piece of
advice we give to our clients.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Labels?
SPEAKER: Labels, labels, labels.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Is
there anything else?
SPEAKER: Well, although more
data is generally better,
it has to be the
right kind of data.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
sounds pretty important.
Maybe like rule
number two important?
Rule number 2, although more
data is generally better,
it has to be the
right kind of data.
Continuing with our example,
if you want your algorithm
to predict credit card fraud,
imagine all the information
a human being might rely
on to do the same task.
Data like the amount
of the transaction
and where it took
place are definitely
useful, but cardholder name?
That may not be as helpful here.
If you're not sure, erring
on the side of more data
is always wise.
In the world of
machine learning,
we don't always know with
100% certainty what's going
to be relevant ahead of time.
Expect to refine as you go.
Sometimes relevant
also means granular.
Suppose you wanted to predict
weather on an hourly basis,
but your data is only collected
daily, let's say 3:00 PM.
Your model will learn how to
predict the weather, sure.
But except for those
of us who decide
what to wear based on the
temperature outside at exactly
3:00 PM, the model won't be
as helpful as it could be.
This also means collecting
data long enough.
So if the target you're
trying to predict
is periodic, like
ice cream sales,
you'll need enough
cycles for your model
to discover the general trend.
A good rule of thumb
is at least three.
This table includes
plenty of helpful columns,
but which one that ML models
depend on to make accurate
predictions is still missing.
[CLOCK TICKING]
You guessed labels, right?
Just checking.
Rule number 3, beware
of biased data.
Granularity matters.
But some errors
only become obvious
when we take a big
step backwards.
It's just like how we
can tell when a picture
frame is leaning
to one side when
we're standing far enough away.
Here, we'll define
bias as anytime
you're training data
skews towards some groups
more than the rest.
Let's say you're trying to
predict customer satisfaction.
Well, we know that
online reviews
tend to overrepresent
the most extreme views.
So if you choose to train a
model on these reviews alone,
your model could become biased.
Now, don't be alarmed if
you have missing values
in a large data set.
But you should check to
see whether these missing
values frequently leave
out the same group.
You might think that
simply collecting more data
will solve the problem, but
that's not always possible.
And even if it were, that's
only a part of the solution.
Just as important,
if you have a way
to tell what dynamics
are causing the bias,
you may still be able
to quantify the effect
and correct it by,
for example, adjusting
the weighing and different
samples accordingly.
Expect to do some
corrections of your data
set, and don't let perfect
be the enemy of great.
Congratulations, you're
more than halfway
to maximizing the power
of your training data.
Now let's finish strong
with some data preparation.
Rule number 4, use
consistent terms.
You'll want to make sure
you're using the same units
across your data set.
Check not only for
quantitative units like price,
but for categorical
units as well.
This also means making sure the
meaning of the data in a given
column is consistent.
If a single price column
switches between wholesale
and retail price, and
you're missing a column that
identifies which is which, your
model will treat these numbers
as though they measure the same
thing, even though they don't.
Rule number 5,
out-think data leakage.
Data leakage happens when you
train your model on information
that won't be available when
it's time for your model
to actually do its job.
So here's my favorite example.
Let's say you're
teaching a model
to pick out which acoustic
recordings contain calls
from an endangered
species of whale.
[WHALE CALL]
What if the recordings
with the right audio
happened to be the same
file size, but only
due to some processing
that was done on them?
Your model could learn to rely
on file size instead of sound,
and later, when it's time
to start making predictions,
label all kinds of
sounds as whale.
Almost done.
Let's quickly review
the basic principles.
Labels, labels, labels;
more data is good,
but it has to be the right
kind; beware of biased data;
use consistent terms
throughout your spreadsheets;
and rule out data leakage.
And voila, you're ready
to select the right data
and make sure it's cooked and
good for your machine learning
algorithm.
For a more detailed
explanation, check out
the full article on the
Google Cloud Platform blog
and find the link to our ML data
prep check list at the bottom.
Have a tip you'd like
to share with us?
Join the conversation
on our Twitter
handle using #mldataprep.
And as always,
thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]